con el congreso porque depende del
presupuesto que ellos apoyen para que
siga viniendo la ayuda financiera Para
apoyar la guerra entonces este agradece
todos los millones de dólares que se han
enviado de Estados Unidos aprobados por
la cámara como él decía de manera
bicameral y bipartidista y ahora que
viene el nuevo congreso que va a ser de
mayoría republicana es importante
mantener la presión y venir en persona
para recordarle a los republicanos lo
importante que es esta ayuda financiera
y que no cumplan sus amenazas de de
disminuirla por eso el tono de
agradecimiento claro quería preguntarle
también sobre lo que ha dicho evoludie
mercedensky no solo al pueblo
estadounidense no solo a los políticos
estadounidenses sino al resto del mundo
ha hablado de que esta guerra es muy
importante no solo para liberar a Europa
y a Ucrania sino también para un futuro
marcar un punto de inflexión para lo que
ha dicho en los países del sur global
puedan liberarse de la tiranía rusa en
sus palabras hablado también de que
esperan que los rusos en algún momento
se puedan librar del kremlin y ayudar a
quitar esta guerra Qué importancia
tienen estas palabras No solo a Estados
Unidos sino al resto de la comunidad
internacional
Sí sigue este discurso de biden de que
estamos viendo en el mundo de hoy una
guerra ideológica y en este caso real
entre la democracias y y los regímenes
autoritarios entonces hizo referencia
por ejemplo a Irán a la amenaza rusa no
solamente en Ucrania sino en otras en
otros países de su esfera de influencia
política y también en incursiones
ideológicas y de desinformación por
ejemplo las elecciones de Francia en
elecciones de otros países en África en
Latinoamérica entonces este tal vez en
Estados Unidos todos están haciendo esta
guerra que no es solamente el del
interés Nacional de los de la gente de
Ucrania sino que es algo que está
diciendo que hay que mantener un frente
Unido en contra de la de la
interferencia
del kremlin en asuntos de otras naciones
alrededor del mundo y le quiero volver a
preguntar en concreto sobre esa
integridad territorial de Ucrania es
posible llegado a este punto de la
guerra con Rusia ya en posesión de
algunos territorios ucranianos que una
futura Paz entre ambos países acabe con
la devolución de esos territorios a
Ucrania O podría ser una moneda de
intercambio para finalizar esta guerra
Esa es la pregunta del millón algunos
piensan que por alguna negociación con
Rusia se debe al parte del territorio y
así finiquitar la guerra sobre todo con
esos esas regiones que Argumenta el
kremlin que son de mayoría rusa y que
supuestamente se ha declarado
independientes de Ucrania sin embargo
parece que los
las encuestas serias que se han hecho en
estas regiones incluso gente que habla
ruso no quieren ser parte de Rusia
entonces estas poblaciones son captivas
y se le es que ha sido muy claro que
ellos no están dispuestos a aceptar eso
Por lo pronto que quieren retomar todo
su territorio original antes de la
invasión Por lo cual están dispuestos a
seguir peleando por esto y es parte lo
que vino a vender a Washington el día de
hoy que siga el apoyo militar para
seguir esa guerra de defensa para
recuperar y mantener la integridad
territorial de Ucrania